evening and welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight Friday's inauguration looks like
it could be a protest event for the ages
with thousands of anti Donald Trump
agitators descending on the city and why
wouldn't they
advertisements posted more than 20
cities have been recruiting paid
protesters to come here to DC help
disrupt the inauguration the group
demand protests which describes itself
as quote the largest grassroots support
organization in the United States says
it will pay professional protestors $50
an hour in addition to a $2,500 monthly
retainer to support their efforts we're
joined now by Dom tulip so director of
operations in Los Angeles for demand
protests Tom thanks for joining us
tonight
yeah no problem Tucker so this is a sham
your company isn't real your website is
fake the claims you have made our lives
this is a hoax let me start at the
beginning however with your name dum
tulip so which is not your real name
it's a fake name well we ran you through
law enforcement level background checks
and that name does not exist let's start
out with the truth tell me what your
real name is it's Dominic - yeap so it's
a / L sir silent that's a lie and you
know it's a lie and we asked you for ID
at the Los Angeles Bureau and you said
you didn't have ID with you but Delos
you have a wallet on you every grown man
does hold up a credit card you can cover
the number to our camera and show us any
piece of documentation with the name
Dominic - leap so on it and you can't
because that's not sure we're sure sure
a plea I'll do that in just a moment I
might just begin with kind of wondering
Tucker you're not accusing this me of
being a hoax are you I'm saying that
your name is fake and this company is
fake and that the claims you've made on
your website are false and so my
question for you is only is this an out
will to discredit the protesters at the
Trump inauguration is it an effort to
convince conservative news organizations
to pick up the story and therefore
highlight their gullibility what's the
point of the ruse that you're
perpetuating on the American news media
sure absolutely great questions I'm
basically there's no way that a
legitimate news agency would have
somebody on that didn't really know what
they were saying or was just kind of
talking out of their behinds there's a
certain amount of vetting that goes on
behind every news organization so I
would assume that I wouldn't be given
airtime on a national stage unless I was
legitimate
well I'm vetting you right now and I'm
beginning by saying you are not
legitimate you are lying we know that
you have fooled other news organizations
you did not fool us and my question is
why are you doing it and and I guess let
me just satisfy our viewers may be
thinking well maybe we're miss calling
this on your website you claim that you
pay a retainer to 1817 operatives every
month now if that were actually true
that's fifty four million dollars a year
you're spending just on retainers
it's another thirty million a year if
you're paying them for six hours a week
work that's demonstrably yeah millon
you're not doing that no we're actually
doing 80 million a year so I don't know
quite where you got those numbers but
those are definitely obviously dated no
one when mentioned the fact wait wait so
although you're you're not exceeding
that this is a hoax you're saying that
this is a real company that's engaged in
the activities you say it's engaged to
have the you're hiring protesters the
you have 1800 of them already on
retainer for twenty-five hundred bucks a
month and that you're affecting American
politics by doing this yeah we actually
changed her mind though about about
we're no longer actually going after
Donald Trump we're actually going after
the protesters at the inauguration so we
kind of changed our minds actually
recently and that was a result mainly of
the enormous amount of hate mail that we
received people you know making death
threats and they basically just really
talked us into changing our position so
what we're doing now is we're actually
protesting the protesters okay with that
next reason that didn't happen because
you don't have a physical address
because you don't have a real office
your website was just put up your
Facebook page same thing you haven't
been receiving hate mail because you
exist okay so if you do exist why don't
you give me some evidence that your real
beginning with your actual name which is
not Dominic to leap oh and by the way
your business partner doesn't exist
either
- let's just be aware I mean let's do a
real yeah
what is the real story here why are you
doing this what point are you trying to
make yeah
the main point basically is that we are
greatly greatly supportive of national
treasures such as Julian Assange Edward
Snowden Peyton Manning right and we
really support their efforts to really
get the truth out there and in the case
of the current client that we have right
now that client is very interested in
releasing the roswell papers no it
really so you're pretty supportive of
Peyton Manning are you extremely yeah
yeah you're not gonna be now
this is performance art I will say
you're pretty good at it when you
convince papers like The Washington
Times which ran this pretty straight to
run your lies to run this host which I
will concede is kind of amusing what was
the point of that I mean beyond just
amusing yourself are you trying to make
a political statement I don't know I
mean it's pretty pretty darn easy these
days to just say whatever the heck you
want on national TV and have it pass off
his truth yeah and you know it's pretty
I don't know it's just pretty incredible
to me how easy it was to get the
coverage we got by the way I'm not
saying any of this is a hoax or any of
this isn't true we've actually got one
hundred thousand protesters going to
Washington DC to fight anybody who is
opposed to Donald Trump I mean the
reason we shift another main reason we
shifted from being against Trump to
Trump about thirty minutes ago was
basically we realized initially he
didn't really like he didn't really like
Julian Assange or Peyton Manning and
when he kind of changed when the
election and the Assange connection was
made he essentially became a supporter
of Assange and so we are now supporting
Trump in the hope that the roswell
documents from 1947 are finally released
and put back
to the hands of Fisher Stevens the
critical Roswell documents all right
we'll give my best to Peyton Manning and
also to mrs. tilly Poe if you would
thanks all for joining us leap Dom tree
so Teebs the Hecker whoever you are get
Philippe last question I'm sorry did you
think that we were gonna fall I mean I'd
be honest do you think you're in come on
we're really I'm just surprised I'm you
put me on
that's what surprising because it's
showed up all over across American media
I'm reading this I was saying well
that's not true
who is this guy so I'm glad you came on
to Stephanie explain well god god bless
you for for fact-checking even if you
did it when we were on the air oh no we
knew ahead of time it's good to see
anyway thanks a lot thanks